yeah one big patch too close you're
really okay with Soviets temperature
sighs the president of America
[Music]
today we're gonna get
one of the biggest markets in peshawar
Carcano markets
where I've been told they sell
absolutely everything
karna no it's a little bit of a process
getting a taxi this morning
we honor it me so two dollars basically
okay okay
[Music]
here we are our auto markets thank you
sukhiya it's like a pretty hardcore
place
let's get into it bye-bye
okay
so what we're gonna do guys is suss it
out a little bit with the camera here
40k to the Afghan border you know
sometimes in new New Frontiers like this
it's
you got to get the feel of what's going
on maybe they like the camera maybe they
don't I'm not sure
I'll get what I can get
you might have to put it down but the
goal is to get into some connectivity
here to get him
as far as conversation like yesterday
yesterday in Peshawar was amazing
constantly people just came out of the
woodwork wanting to connect and I was
never alone
I'm gonna go this right then I'm gonna
take your advice
well that's some good advice right don't
go don't go past the British from people
so what he took a detour what's that
what do you tend for you
he said don't don't go past the bridge
there it's dangerous dangerous it's
dangerous the police who has straining
water they're dangerous
how about the police here that is agency
district that's agency district but the
government the government has control of
this district right yeah
this is fine yeah this is the control
eighty that tournament has control it
yes so it's safe yeah it is very sick
very safe
yeah cool City let's check let's check
out this market what are we gonna sit I
like these hats yeah it's a traditional
Pashtun
we got nuts here you will show you
blenders down in the cosmetics it's a
patch market lot going on this is the
solar area solar panel area I didn't
know you guys win the solar panels it's
for people living in the countryside so
let me ask you this now that we have
some quietness and we can probably hear
it on camera what is unique about the
Pashtun question like what are your
characteristics is that they're very
friendly and also hospitable yeah you
like for union people better yeah I felt
that for sure in two days here they feel
very loyal yeah and they take
responsibility like you met me over
there and you like taking responsibility
for me to some degree right why not I
want to take your responsibility you can
live with me even leave my clearance
yeah why not this guy's got the watches
going here
my friend mr. dan he's also my friend
it's beautiful okay
Salam alaikum do you want to watch no
I'm good on watches thank you thank you
okay there's no perfect first nice nice
covers these these are all Pakistani are
where these from yeah these are Pakistan
Punjab Punjab Punjab II yeah okay
job this is all pooja be no no not
Pakistani people Thoresen and here we
got official people also okay
Salam aleikum people are wearing this
serious we got a cloth do is chop juice
job Barger so basically everything you
need for life is in this margin okay so
we're holding hands here yeah and it's
not a homosexual thing it's it's close
friendship thing and past my culture so
a lot of times you see men men holding
hands walking the streets it's a very
touchy feely place in space does it
really exist between people
my crazy shirt Sadiq cuz my preemies
I've got a fabric shop okay okay
assalamu alaikum oh yeah peace be with
you
a sulli on the Prophet Muhammad of
course another did you get that it goes
on we're gonna say them so look at the
juxtapositions here you have guys
cooking on the on the ground and a new
metro way above let me show you the back
part
a good a video in this market this is
the busy one right some easy ones okay
[Music]
okay H come this is a we gonna pee we're
getting in with this guy
Salam alaikum
Salam alaikum okay so why are we in the
Panda yeah why are the way we're being
too forward paws are okay
welcome welcome to the wagon my lecture
begins
you ready for this see we have a new
brother here he said we're already in
the same space right yeah exactly it's
one big family
one big pasture then I asked him a
questions that do manking why not he
likes me yeah why I like him
[Music]
that's good right now everyone's liking
each other in the van
it is very insurance in lots of
Afghanistani people
jairs leaving here
first gun
okay
that was a quick stop and we got a crowd
going
these are laughs Kenny's yeah they're
gonna be friendly very friendly
I'm also a bunny living shower okay my
places and I wonder standing a hat
and I also study in the shower both of
our University PS political side posture
oh yes you speak English very well
fifty fifty percent yes what's your name
my name is there Willy roly-poly Rizzoli
ceraadi
we should your refugee in Pakistan yeah
how many years have you lived yeah
40s for years 40 40 40 40 years I'm
singing about a family that since four
years okay you know what Angela the
Soviets come here take care of my friend
NARR today okay so his family was
involved with the Soviet key hard right
and they moved here and so do do Afghan
ease and Pakistanis get along okay and
Peshawar no I'm just asking I don't know
they do they're leaving
since 88 1980
living here and everyone's Pashtun right
everyone especially massive
vegetable markets
the motorcycle car keoki don't keep the
cards here this guy manages this place
she's like he's the person up Gordon
page
gotcha the reason I wore this today was
not because I'm Muslim because I'm not
it's to cut the the foreign look which
isn't doing a damn thing obviously but
people seem to like it and then it's
these these caps are very comfortable
good sun protection hello
and they're comfortable I like it much
better than a baseball cap for any other
type of collection
back into a fabric town do you want to
see this market wonderful okay
for me right okay yeah close you're
ready okay okay they wouldn't close this
video so these are these for special
ceremonies deadly Vegas yeah we can see
phenomena company is your paper tech
person tech person yeah how are you
doing well yeah welcome to thank you
what are you selling here making
curtains curtains okay if you want to
mix I will make you for you some
curtains I'm good on the curtains but
thank you
okay you have so are you are you Afghani
or Pakistani I'm basically from
clandestine but I hope I'm wearing here
and I could smell your hair okay
from the past 40 years gotcha yeah yes I
see Soviet Union war after that refugees
can have only freezes here in Pakistan
so from that time we have been living in
here in Pakistan we are educating
ourselves as a student of CS computer
science very cool
third semester almost anything so you
want to be a developer yeah you'll still
stop doing this yeah supporting ourself
yeah isn't making our education easier
for some who will be doing this work if
all the young people are gonna be
developing and coding and doing other
work who will be doing this work yeah
it's you know the generation generation
to generation
things are happening just like the same
way repeatedly
only this is the Academy of English lots
of people are coming here to learn
English there are very beneful
instructors
[Music]
you should come
Salam alaikum so this is your English
school yeah this my English incident
okay
[Music]
you guys ready for class where's the
class
and I love the way you have dressed off
like a very typical Pakistani style and
the way people are grooming around you
it's a message to the president of an
America Donald Trump we love the way
I've heard it all I've heard it all yes
please what a what an experience
okay so what did you say yeah but
managing donek just say the don't make
human becomes your team example female
yeah and they don't want to be on camera
reacts and
so that was interesting I never know how
these things are gonna play out and it
was started as a tour of a market ended
up middle school so that's what it's
like outside of Peshawar Pakistan whoo
these are very intense stimulating
exhausting amazing days okay until next
time
like and subscribe if you want to
support this channel hit the
notification bell to be the first to see
my next video many more videos about
Pakistan and other parts of the world
coming soon